[Music]
so
hey everyone welcome to the table
on the sunday evening the very last
sunday of january
we made it made it to the end of january
congratulations
for some of us that's a big deal and so
no matter what you've been through this
month
i am so glad you're here my name is
karen miner
and uh here we are it's another sunday
got my tea
again my table mug where everyone has a
seat at the table
uh so glad you're with us if
you are joining us live and even if
you're not
uh i would love for you to comment down
below let us know that you're here
let us know that you're watching i love
to see
people's names pop up and see who's
tuning in and joining us so make sure to
say hello we'd love a chance to connect
with you directly and personally
i just have a couple of announcements
tonight the first one
is about our meetups our meetups are
getting up and running again
in the new year and the one i'd like to
spotlight tonight is our men's group
uh this is a great group that's led by
daryl adams
who's a wonderful guy a long time member
of the table
and a personal friend of mine and his
men's group meets weekly
every tuesday night at 7 00 pm and it's
a great bunch of guys
they get together every week to
encourage one another
pray together worship together
it's it's just a wonderful group and so
for any of you who
identify as male i'd love for you to get
in touch with daryl
you can email him for more information
about this group
his email address is daryl d-a-r-y-l
at thetabletx.org
or you can just comment down below let
us know you're interested in the men's
group and we'll connect you guys with uh
with daryl
so i hope you'll check that out secondly
next weekend on sunday it's the super
bowl
and the super bowl starts right in the
middle of our
usual table service so we're going to do
a big favor
you sports fans and we're going to start
an hour earlier
so next sunday our service will start at
4 pm
instead of 5 p.m you can still jump
online and watch it five
you just won't be joining us live so i
hope you'll join us either way
but if you'd like to tune into the live
stream we'll be starting at 4 p.m
next week all right well as we jump into
music which by the way is amazing
tonight
let's just take some time to center and
pray
and remember why we do this each week
god we breathe in your spirit
tonight we take a deep breath
and remember that all things flow from
you
you are the source of life of breath
of spirit of hope
and love so we take a moment
to become newly aware of that
freshly aware of that we take a moment
to center on
you jesus remembering that you
are the physical representation
of the character and nature of god
so god as we go into the service and
into the week ahead help us to remember
you to remember your character and your
nature
to breathe in your spirit to be filled
by your spirit to be led
by your spirit
to respond instead of react to take a
beat take a breath
before speaking to listen to breathe you
in
and to remember that your presence is
always around us and that your love is
always around us
thank you god for your goodness and
faithfulness and
we ask that we would be open to what you
have for us tonight
in jesus name amen
hello framily
good to be with you guys again thank you
karen i'm excited
about tonight i love it when new faces
are a part of our live stream
and we're gonna have some of that
tonight and it's just been
so refreshing um seeing different people
jump into the service at different
points and it always just
um it's kind of that mixed bag like on
the one hand it makes me miss being
together when we got to see each other
on a regular basis
but it also like makes me treasure those
moments when you know you see someone's
face and you hear their voice and you're
like oh my gosh i've missed that person
so much so um anyways i'm just excited
to be with you guys even those of you
that i don't get to hear your voice or
see your face tonight um seeing your
comments and seeing people jump on
is always just such a blessing um just
to remember
um our times together and to cherish the
ones that we have
right now so we're gonna get started and
um
there was a poem that gary wrote one
time and i'm kicking myself because i
meant to contact him earlier to have him
resend it i've searched all my files in
the last
few minutes and i can't find it but
there's this one line that just stands
out in my
mind and it's just been like repeating
like a mantra in my mind
the last couple of days it's so simple
but it says
we are the brave ones and um
i think it's easy sometimes um
especially in
our uh evangelical
worship circle to kind of come
sometimes as almost like he
we posture ourselves and i and i get it
i think there's some healthiness to this
but
you know what i mean like as as the
sinner as uh the lost one the broken one
the undone one and although
there's truth in all of that for me
personally there's truth and all of that
and every time
i'm coming into a conversation with the
maker of the stars
there is that feeling of finite weakness
um in me but i also want us to remember
even in some of these words as it's
talking about us
you know as sometimes lost ones as frail
creations to also remember that um
we are also the brave ones and we come
into this space
we can come into this space unafraid um
and ready to engage one another and
the maker of the universe um with
confidence
with love with freedom newfound freedom
and so i hope that we're able to
experience that together tonight while
we're worshiping
maggie's going to go ahead and play for
us
her beautiful skills so you all just
join in from home
as you're able to wherever you are
this is a call to all the dead and
disappointment
the ones who feel like they are done
this is a word to all the ones who feel
[Music]
forgotten
you
we are soaked in all the grace that
we've been given
unchained from all that we have done
your mercy's rising like the sun on the
horizon cause we're
coming home here we go
[Music]
alive
a
[Music]
i think she heard it in the other room
and thought this is my moment
they're doing my song
hey everybody
you gotta love the at-home worship
rawness
i mean what's cuter than a
three-year-old being like
yes it's my solo this is my song
okay where did you start let's take it
from that chorus
[Music]
alive
alive in you
yes lord we are grateful
for your grace and for your love
for your grace
yes lord we are grateful
for your grace and for
your love
yes lord we are grateful
for your grace and for
[Music]
yourself
shame and you covered me with grace
[Music]
you are the hand that reaches out to
save
i am serious
[Music]
it is
you are the hand that reaches
[Music]
it is for freedom
i am
[Music]
and yes lord we are
grateful for your grace
and for your love
yes lord we are grateful
for your grace and for your
love yes lord
[Music]
gracious
you are the hand that reaches out to
save
and i am set free
[Music]
i am
that i am
oh my god keep setting us free
keep showing us where we're brave braver
than we realize
god thank you for believing in us
we just want to stay in that posture
believing
that you are the one who created us you
know us
[Music]
we're gonna pass it on over to gary and
he's gonna do
known and loved so you guys enjoy
thank you so much that was really good
and um yeah kind of a
emotional spot right now so please bear
with me
we've been hiding
in the shadows lost
and of you
we've been wandering
in the darkness but if we only knew
we are known in love
known in love we are
known and loved by you
cause we are known in love
known in love we are
known and loved by you
[Music]
you've been waiting
to show us mercy
your presence is our home
will your children
love forever
every fear is gone
we are unknown
love by you
so we are known in love
known in love we are
known in love by you
there is no fear
[Music]
anymore
that's all that's left is mercy
there is no fear
in your love
[Applause]
there is no fear
anymore
it's all that's left is mercy
there is no fear in your love
in your love
as we are known in love
known in love we are
known and loved by you
we are known in love
known in love we
are known and loved
by you
it's on this next part just open up your
hands and just receive
this truth and there
is no fear
[Applause]
[Music]
anymore
because all that's left is mercy
there is no fear
in your love
[Music]
because you're the god of mercy
there is no fear
anymore
as you're the god of mercy
there is no fear
anymore
cause all that's left is mercy
there is no fear
[Music]
in your love
yeah father god we thank you that you
are the god of love
and mercy and goodness we praise you
lord
and we give you all the glory tonight
and father i pray for brett
rather be with him as he speaks and
delivers your heart
and god i hope that we have ears to hear
and hearts are open to receive it
it's in jesus name i pray amen
amen thank you gary
um this powerful powerful powerful song
and
i um i know
that was that that word of god's
um heart god's
posture towards us is not one
of hate or vengeance or payback
or angry or anger but
god is full of love
that's um this is what we've learned
from jesus right this is who jesus has
revealed god to be
and um so thank you for that
beautiful beautiful reminder uh so good
evening everyone
grace and peace i'm really really
grateful
so grateful just to be with you all and
uh a special welcome for anyone who is
new to the table
um one of our values is that we be
inclusive
that's our value inclusive of i mean
everyone
regardless of you know gender race
sexual orientation
or even of how like religious or
christian you may or may not be
or consider yourself or something um you
know regardless
just welcome welcome so this is a part
four
in our series titled epiphany a radical
invitation
and uh the season of epiphany and the
church calendar
is basically it's the perfect follow-up
to the season of advent so
if you're familiar with advent you know
it leads up to christmas it's all about
waiting on god it's all about receiving
something from
god that we could not give ourselves
namely the gift of jesus but epiphany is
about our
response to that gift which is why it
comes after the christmas eve
season so it's this um really this
radical invitation and
call to discipleship and faithfulness to
the way of christ
so with that in mind the title of my
message tonight
is a little bit odd it's idols meat
and beliefs idols meat and beliefs and
our primary text
will be a portion of a letter that the
apostle paul wrote to a church in the
city of corinth
found in 1st corinthians chapter 8
verses 1 through 9
and verse 13 and the issues described
there may
sound uh somewhat irrelevant to our
cultural moment
but i encourage you to kind of look
underneath the issue
so to speak um and and kind of look to
the the deeper temptations
um and processes kind of residing within
it because i do believe those things are
highly relevant
for our time and place uh so tonight our
very own
caleb rob will be uh giving our
scripture reading so
uh take it away caleb
hello i'm kayla thank you so much for
letting me read this passage for you so
today we're going to be reading from
first corinthians 8. i'm just going to
get started
um we're starting at verse 1. now about
food sacrifice to idols
we know that we all possess knowledge
but knowledge
puffs up while love builds up those who
think they know something
do not yet know as they ought to know
but whoever loves god is known by god
so then about eating food sacrificed to
idols
we know an idol is nothing at all in the
world
and that there is no god but one for
even if there are so-called gods whether
in heaven or on earth as indeed there
are many gods and many lords yet for us
there is but one god the father
from whom all things came and for whom
we live
and there is but one lord jesus christ
through whom all things came and through
whom
we live but not everyone possesses this
knowledge
some people are still so accustomed to
idols that when
they eat sacrificial food they think of
it as having been sacrificed to a god
and
since their conscience is weak it is
defiled but
food does not bring us near to god we
are
no worse if we do not eat and know
better if we do
be careful however that the exercise
of your rights does not become stumbling
block
to the weak therefore
if what i eat causes my brother or
sister to fall into sin
i will never eat meal again i'll never
eat meat again
so that i will not cause them to fall
thank you my friend all right so
this kind of brings up the question what
on earth was going on
2 000 years ago in the life of this
ancient church
and why do they keep talking about meat
and idols
so in the ancient world when an
animal was religiously sacrificed the
whole animal was
not necessarily burned up rather a
portion
was offered to the god and then another
portion was cooked and consumed
immediately
often by the family who like offered the
sacrifice
or paid for it so to speak and then yet
another portion was offered to the
priest
uh for consumption and then finally the
rest
was sometimes later sold off in other
words in the ancient
um world temples to various gods kind of
kept
helped keep themselves financially
viable um
by selling meat uh because that was
quite a you know it was quite a luxury
back then um so here we kind of have the
origins for a very
um contentious issue in the first
century church
can christians eat meat sacrifice to
idols to these pagan deities
uh one side of christian believers said
of course not like that is
pagan demonic meat who knows
what spirits might be infused into it i
mean if you think about it eating
is not just eating eating is a spiritual
act it's
it's a taking in and in fact everything
is a spiritual act
and so we should pay very close
attention
to where our food comes from they said
uh furthermore
when we purchase such meat we are
supporting
the pagan temple industrial complex
an entire system of oppressive spiritual
structures
and as believers and the one true god
who is father son and spirit
we cannot in good conscience partake in
such activities
so uh that's kind of where they're
coming from uh
it's pretty i'm persuaded it's a pretty
good argument all right but the other
side
and apparently the apostle paul was more
aligned with this perspective
they said that the knowledge that there
is only one true god means that at
best these so-called lowercase g-gods
are like
demi-gods or fallen angels that is you
know they're created things
and thus they in no way pose a threat
to the god who is the source the the
ground of everything that is
and and that's that's the best i mean at
worst heck these demigods
may not even exist at all like they
could just be literally
figments of people's imaginations fables
from humanity's pagan and highly
superstitious past
which is to say that eating meat
sacrificed to an idol
is eating meat sacrifice to a nothing
sacrificed nothing at all and so
actually followers of christ
they contended partaking in a meal with
this kind of meat
it is an exercise in christian freedom
we do not live we do not eat in
fear fear of devils demons or demigods
of any sort
whom the sun sets free is free indeed
can i get an amen
um i mean that's also it's pretty
persuasive now as i hinted out above
this issue simply is not an issue for us
today
i think you'll agree on this no one goes
to kroger and like
checks with the butcher you know like
hey um
so this meat was it like prepared in
some sort of ritual to a pagan deity i'm
just that's
important for me um no that said no one
ever
um or at least not in our day so so at
one level
uh like i said this is just a totally
outdated and and irrelevant issue for us
uh but i think it's still instructive
because it is an example of a
highly emotional issue on which
christians disagreed see what's hard
is when the issue becomes charged
electric with judgment
anxiety and fear
here's the key word see whenever we are
experiencing
intense um unpleasant emotions or
negative emotions
um look underneath them for the fear
ask yourself what am i afraid of
and i think that's why this example from
first corinthians 8 is so
remarkably powerful because my hunch
is that there there was just a lot of
fear around this
for the uh anti-idol meet folks
it was probably a fear of demon
possession in fact they may have said
something
you know something like this what what
if you're opening yourself
up to malevolent spiritual powers by
eating that
that's that's dangerous and i'm afraid
for you
for us for the implications of what you
are doing
to yourself and your children and future
generations
anyone ever heard maybe an argument goes
along those lines even if it's made
about a different issue
and on the other side my hunch is it may
have been the fear of control
we know that the corinthian congregation
was largely gentile that is not jewish
and if you're familiar with early
christian history then you know
that the relationship of jewish
christians and gentile christians
was contentious and difficult
uh the jewish christian believers they
were very
tempted to say that these gentiles in
order to
really follow christ they needed to
become good jews first
you know the men needed to be
circumcised they all need to follow
certain food laws keep certain festival
days
and believe jesus is the son of god
uh and thus i suspect the reason this
became so contentious
for the other side was because the
gentiles were thinking
here they go again always
trying to control us if we
relent here if we fail
to draw a line in the sand here
fail to demand our rights there is
nothing they will not try to take from
us
enough is enough simeon pass me the
brisket
all right i waited all week to say that
all right so admittedly um
i'm sort of reading into the text and i
don't know exactly what was going
through their minds
but i'm fairly certain that this was a
very contentious
issue for the first century church and
because it had to do with demonic forces
and pagan rituals and such it was likely
a very emotionally charged issue
and like i said above that that's the
difficulty
the most difficult conversations are
emotionally
charged conversations conversations
where the content
lends itself to the sense of fear
and thus to anger
and this is why i believe 1st
corinthians 8 has so much wisdom and
insight for us today
because while we may not be talking
about
you know meat sacrifice to idols anymore
there are a whole host of
emotionally charged issues and events
going on
in our world that not only christians
disagree on but frankly
just humans as a whole disagree on which
begs the question how on earth do i
relate to those i strongly disagree with
let me say that again that's the
question
how on earth do i relate to those i
strongly disagree with
do i cut them off do i
do i try to change them do i
compromise is compromise wisdom
or weakness is it is it good
to argue to take a stand for the truth
or is that just pride is listening to
those i disagree with
an act of christian charity or
is it plain nice with the oppressor
what am i to do can can you relate to
any of those questions uh i hope so
because those are like the questions of
our day
and i think paul names a number of
things
that sort of poke at us
uh not at other people not the people we
think are so dumb irrational ill
informed
he's poking at us and he's asking
is your ego in the driver's seat right
now
and honestly the last few years uh for
for me have been one extended exercise
in difficult conversations and extended
exercise and how to
i mean basically how to disagree well uh
many of you know that the table
uh or this church community is a gay
affirming church plant
um but our back story is that we have
deep roots in a previous church
community
uh one that is more traditionalist more
conservative whatever you want to kind
of call it
um in their position on that topic and
so we went
through months of
really difficult conversations uh this
was in about mid-2019
uh trying to understand trying to come
to
agreement and uh let me tell you
ego was lurking in the corner
of every single conversation
uh i'm i used that metaphor of lurking
in the corner because i'm not saying
the whole thing was just driven by ego
and everyone was just egomaniacs i'm not
saying that i'm saying it was just
it was there as a temptation
all day every day like every
conversation
in fact i'm almost certain that um
mentors and leaders kind of over me at
that time uh over
over a number of us that they were um
very tempted
notice i said tempted to lash out
with something like this but since when
do you just ignore god's word
and uh and then i of course
was tempted to rage yell well since when
did you become
such a pharisee who holds the letter of
the law and ignores the spirit of the
law the law of love
the highest law have you heard of it uh
now the truth is neither of us uh said
those things
um out loud we just you know just
thought them
um but we didn't say them and why didn't
we say them
uh well because it just wasn't true
those things just aren't true and it
might be it might be different with the
people you've had to process this
with so i'm just speaking for myself my
own experience and the people i was
interacting with um and this
in that case you know these extreme kind
of statements
these very ego driven statements these
they just weren't they just were not
true um the truth is uh
we love the bible i love the bible here
at the table um
and the truth is they love people i have
no doubt they love
all different kinds of people um it was
it was just really difficult it was just
a difficult conversation
because the stakes were very high and
there was a lot of
fear fear that we would make them look
bad
that people would judge them
fear that they would make us look bad
that people would judge us
fear it was
it was meat sacrifice to idols all over
again
and that same dynamic plays out today
uh for some of you it's the conversation
i just mentioned you know sexual
orientation
um if you're part of the lgbtq community
this is you know part of your your life
is these kinds of difficult
conversations
especially if you're coming from like a
christian background
um or it could even just be your own
viewpoint or stance on this
if um if you're not part of the lgbtq
community just an ally
um right that's it's just a big deal to
to people you like to
to be in a different place than others
and then the question is how do
you have that conversation how do you
relate in the midst of that
um so that's just one issue though i
mean for for others like
well heck honestly for all of us right
now it's it's all sorts of politics
all sorts of i mean all the issues oh
everything left right
it's like we're just we're just
in very different places in this country
and you get this conflict of visions
this
conflict of of humanity this view of
humanity and of society and how
things should be run and and i mean just
how much we should focus on systems
versus the individual
and like how are we gonna solve all
these things
i mean it's a hot mess right and on and
on i could go
um but here's the thing i think paul has
such
wisdom for us on this and like i said i
see him poking
where is he poking i'd like to come back
um to verses
verse one and verse two of first
corinthians eight this is what paul
writes he says we know
that we all possess knowledge
but knowledge puffs up while love
builds up those who think they know
something
do not yet know as they ought
to know let's focus on that second line
those who think they know something do
not yet know as they ought to know
so he's he's saying that it's possible
to know something
and yet know it wrongly
i don't think he means simply that
sometimes people are wrong
i think if you take the whole context of
the passage
he's he's saying even the people that
that agree with his position
can actually be in the wrong like wait
what
i thought it was right he's like well
you are right but you're wrong
it's like what do you mean um and i i
think this
is what he's naming is the way they know
it
the way they know what they know is
wrong i found clarity
on this a number of years ago in the
writings of a christian philosopher
named peter rollins in his book it's a
wonderful book
how not to speak of god how parentheses
not do you speak of god and there he
names
that it's not enough to believe the
truth or to believe true things
we have to believe it in the right way
but what does he mean believe in the
right way he means in a
loving christ-like way
in other words how i believe
the emotional tone the posture of my
heart is every bit as
important as what i believe
how i believe is every bit as important
as what i believe the key words there
are
how and what because the the truth
is um it's not simply like an idea
or any one mental concept that
corresponds to the reality or something
like the capital t
truth is a relationship it is a
way of relating to god to
christ to other people to myself it's a
process
the truth is a process called
love and i've known plenty of people
uh that i intellectually agree with like
heck i've known lots of christians who i
think
are you know essentially right on a lot
of things about you know god christ the
world sin etc
and yet i fear that they are largely
making the world worse
because of how they believe
what they believe the
the smug pride
and ego driven nature of how
they believe is so terribly wrong
but truth be told i'm not trying to just
cast stones because
i mean this gets me too every day like
every single day it gets me this is what
trips us up ego is the enemy
it's what christian writers like thomas
merton called the false self
it's what the apostle paul in other
places the new testament calls the flesh
call it whatever you want but it's the
thing i named earlier it's that
that insecure defensive
angry vengeful resentful prideful
fearful i want to be better than you i
want to be
smarter than you part of us
it uh i mean it's it's sin
basically and the tragedy is that at
precisely the moment
when we think we are most right
precisely when we think well this is not
about me at all it's about the truth
that's precisely when
the flesh slips into the back door
and reasserts itself and suddenly
how we believe is so very very wrong
even though i think paul may say what we
are believing
may be so very very right this is why
paul's other statement uh in the passage
the other key statement
is knowledge puffs up
while love builds up
isn't that beautiful knowledge puffs up
while love builds up i love that phrase
puffs up
puffs up what well really it's
it's puffs up who
again it's me it's it's this part of me
this false self this ego
part of me and one thing that strikes me
is how quick
a puff is just
but how slow and painstaking
building is
you see ego gets puffed up in a second
i can say that with um confidence
because um
i have a massive ego i know it i know it
all too well i mean how quickly
um we will take to social media
to condemn the very beliefs
we ourselves held six weeks
or six months ago
and not just in a way of like hey i
disagree with this now like that would
be not necessary i'm not saying
everything
we you know saying i disagree with
something is ego driven
but you know you get that that righteous
indignation
you know i mean don't you see this all
the time like someone shifts on an issue
like theologically or politically or
something and then all of a sudden it's
like
oh can you believe those people oh my
gosh you know
oh do you mean like you a year ago is
that what you see
this is ego it's a puff just before you
know just
ego is a puff but love
builds up encourages
talks with others and listens
to others engages with them
and in a posture of humility
and patience and love
it moves slowly towards the kingdom
of god you see the kingdom of god the
dream of god for the world
is not puffed into existence
in a moment it is built
slowly as we not simply believe the
right things
but as we above all else believe
in the right way and
and if you think uh that you know all of
the people at the table
um that we all agree and so really this
is about how we relate to
others you know out there in the world
um you are kidding yourself we have got
uh very real disagreements everywhere
but not just at the table i mean in in
our family some of it between
best friends between husbands and wives
between siblings so
so you might ask like what what should i
do
how do i live this out uh i mean the
short version would be
don't be puffed up build
up hold your beliefs in a loving
christ-like manner but i know that can
still be a bit vague
so let me let me give you some more
concrete examples let me kind of spell
this out a bit more clearly
i'm going to give you three um puffed up
says
verse build up says uh kind of closing
statements so puffed up says
because i care i need to change
how you think
this um it's amazing how we love to do
this
and we hate to be on the receiving end
of this
right like we think this about others
like it's because i love you so much i
really need to i need to change you um
and yet when someone's doing this
to us it's like we can feel the control
we can feel the manipulation we can feel
the ego just
jumping out of them but it's so crazy
how
you know when we do it we're just we're
doing it because we love them
because i love and care for you i need
to change how you think that's what
puffed up ego says
build up says because i care
i give you the freedom to think
differently
because i care i give you the freedom to
think differently coming back to the
meat sacrificed to idols i mean this is
effectively what paul's naming
right is he doesn't say yeah those
people are real idiots
so we need to convince them that they're
wrong it's i mean
in fact he criticizes the folks he
agrees with saying
be careful uh in other words i think
what is his name is that our friendship
it's it's not our relationships with
people our connections and it's not
based on intellectual theological
philosophical political agreement
our relationships are built on mutual
love
and respect can you hear the difference
there
see puffed up is threatened by
disagreement
ego is always threatened by disagreement
because it's wildly insecure and afraid
of being wrong
build up is relaxed and
ready to both listen and speak
ready to allow others to be
and to think differently
all right second example puffed up says
your wrong beliefs
are making me uncomfortable your wrong
beliefs are making me
uncomfortable in other words um you're
making me uncomfortable
i just can't be around people who won't
agree with me who won't get on my page
and if you don't agree with me you don't
really love me that's like the very
extreme version of this
if you don't if you won't see it my way
well
you just don't even love me uh that of
course is
just pure like false self
talking um build up says
my discomfort is my own
our disagreement is an opportunity for
me
to grow and mature
uh and this by the way is different than
saying um
you know oh i'm so upset it's my fault
that i'm i'm uncomfortable
like i i hate myself for feeling this
discomfort of this anxiety i'm a failure
like that's not what i'm saying
that's not what i mean by my discomfort
is my own um
there's no need to judge or blame anyone
for feelings emotions and you know
mental
physical states like they just simply
are um
but it is owning look this is this
discomfort it's in me
you didn't make me feel
this way um all right third example
puffed up says if you don't see it my
way
it's because you are being willfully
blind ignorant
and are probably a terrible person
oh god that's so toxic um buildup says
i'm going to give you the benefit of the
doubt
empathize with you and try my best
to see the world through your
eyes maybe then i'll understand
so church uh this
this is our call it's uh it's a high
calling
isn't it building building
is the hard path toughing up that's the
easy path
building in love that's the hard path
but it's the work we are called to do
and i know we can be faithful to it not
perfect
but faithful and i trust that god will
meet us
in the midst of that journey let me pray
for you
lord jesus i
ask that you would give us the grace
god to believe in the right way and to
be
a build up kind of people
help us to be a build up kind of people
people of your spirit people of faith
hope and love
people of patience kindness
humility confidence
boldness
wisdom
god help us to walk this narrow path
and save us from ourselves lord save us
from our false self
our ego
god may we become fully
surrendered to you may we die
to that part of us and become alive
to you god fill us with your spirit
lead us into beauty truth and goodness
it's in the powerful name of jesus that
i pray amen
good word good word um
i am going to do a song by sleeping at
last again it's called
sight and uh josh rollins
is behind the scenes today holding all
of our technology needs together
and he has been so awesome to put all of
our lyrics
up for people to see and um i just
encourage you guys to focus in on the
lyrics
um while i play they're kind of the
heartbeat of the song
and uh they were just so powerful to me
it just kind of
two questions went through my head this
week as i was playing through this song
and thinking about brett's message
and one was like is my posture
honoring the pieces of god that are in
others
regardless of our differences
is it looking for god outside
of the framework that i have created
and say is true so um
if those questions are helpful for you
as you engage this song i just wanted to
share them
um i just yeah i hope you enjoy the
lyrics as much as i do they are just so
powerful to me
[Music]
i see god
in symmetry
[Music]
i see god in our main belief
i see god in our
grand attempts
to make something beautiful
before life ends
i see good
[Music]
in fragile heirlooms within
children's reach
and i see good in
our damn it's good
[Music]
but you see god in ways
i wish i could
without instruction
without obstruction you believe
without containers or
duelistic framework
you see the whole
ghost
in bright
[Music]
daylight
and i see the reflection
in your eyes
i see good
in the sanctuary of
our homes
i seek in
wilderness
in our magnetism to
recklessness
black white we are
vivid color
after a while it all
runs together
[Music]
our stained glass windows
mean nothing without
the light
i see good in our
damaged goods
but you see god in ways i
wish i could
[Music]
you see god in ways i wish i could
withheld assurance
without insurance you believe
without condition
or the promise of heaven
you see the whole
[Music]
daylight
and i see the reflection
in your eyes
[Music]
i see the reflection
in your eyes
thanks mindy i'm sitting here wondering
why did it take us so long to put the
dang lyrics up on the screen
i have so enjoyed seeing the words um
man it just makes every song that much
more
meaningful and powerful and um i even
find myself singing along
which has been good so let's do that
every week i vote for that thank you so
much for joining us
uh what a great reminder tonight was
[Music]
that we need each other and we need
these reminders that we are known and
loved
and that god is a god of love and
that when fear comes we have ways to
deal with it
and we're not meant to do it alone so
one of the cool things about
doing online church is you can go back
and watch these you can share them
[Music]
with friends or family members and so i
just want to say
if as you go into your week you find
yourself
maybe feeling anxious fearful depressed
going down a worry spiral
feeling isolated or alone or just in a
bad mood
which is totally normal uh go back and
and watch this live stream again or just
watch a certain song that really
resonated
with you or watch the message again or
whatever it's always available
for you and we always want to be
available for you
as well so if you're visiting with us
for the first time
or you just like to connect with us we
would really like that too
i believe sarah is going to post a
contact form
which is a very easy way to kick us a
message
you can also go to our website
thetabletx.org
that's the table tx.org
and just click on connect with us it's
in the top right corner of
the home page we would love to hear from
you and we would love to be there for
you
don't forget that next week we'll be
meeting at 4 p.m online
instead of 5 p.m due to the super bowl
and
as you head into your week i just want
to leave you with this benediction
which i i i may sound like a broken
record because
i say this benediction every time that i
do the closing
but i truly believe that
we can never be reminded enough of this
and i hope as you're reminded you take
this with you
into your week and you can bless others
with these same
truths you are a child of god
this is true on your best days and
on your worst days you were wonderfully
and lovingly made there is only one you
nothing about you is a mistake and this
world needs you
being fully yourself authentic and free
so as you go into the week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace
and unconditional love to everyone you
come in contact with
have a great week and we'll see you back
here next sunday at 4. bye-bye
you